[موسيقى]
وقفت الثانيه مع مراسلي الصباح العربيه
هذه المره مع ريان الظاهر طبعا مبادره
ترحيل المسافرين مجانا من الخرطوم الى
الولايات هذه المبادره راح تشرح اكثر عنها
ونتعرف عليها ريان صباح الخير
يسعد صباحكم بالنور
بالفعل
الفاعل جدا في اجلاء او ترحيل للمسافرين
من ولايه الخرطوم الى الولايات الاخرى
الاكثر امانا او ربما ايضا يعبرون من خلال
هذه الولايات
مسافرين الى خارج السودان الاوضاع في
الخرطوم ليست امنه كما تعلمون
واجمل ما في الامر او اكثر ما يتباهى به
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هذه الايام
عدد من الصور ومقاطع الفيديو سكان
الولايات الاخرى يستقبلون سكان ولايه
الخرطوم بالموائد والمياه والعصائر ايضا
والتحلان هذه الصفات
في الزول السوداني وفي الحيه السودانيه
نالت على اعجاب رواد مواقع التواصل
السودان الان هو ربما اللي بيحدد شو هي
الاخبار اللي عملها تطلع بهذه الفتره هناك
ايضا حمله اخرى ووسم
برانا طبعا هو هذا الوسم عاملينه مجموعه
من الشباب تعاهدوا بالمساعده بعد ان تتوقف
الحرب لاعاده بناء السودان حطينا اكثر عن
هذا النقطه راويه والله اول حاجه انا كنت
منتظرك تقولي يعني
شاربه من ميه النيل
طيب بن
بني
بيتصدر الان مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مليء بالتفاؤل والامل بان غدا اجمل باذن
الله تعالى يعني كل شخص من مجال تخصصه
يستطيع ان يقدم خدمات مجانيه
للمواطن السوداني عاقب انتهاء الحرب عليه
ان يتعاقد ويفعل هذا الهاشتاق فهو هاشتاق
يعني يوعد بانه بكره اجمل باذن الله تعالى
اجمل الريان شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لكل هذه
النظرات التفاؤليه للسودانيين شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات